Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm a musician in residence at
Yale University's Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a
companion to our album Where
Is Our Homeland, which is the first
volume in the Archive's ongoing
effort to present songs
and poems performed by survivors
in testimonies given to the
Fortunoff archive over the last
40 years.
You can learn more about the project
on the Archive's Website
songsfromtestimonies.org.
"Where is our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies.
Vol. 1" was recorded in
2019 by the Zisl
Slepovitch Ensemble, featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua
Camp on the accordion, keyboards
and the guitar, Dmitry Ishenko
on the bass, and myself on
woodwinds.
The songs in this collection differ
vastly in terms of style,
social and historical background,
language, and many other aspects.
But collectively, they create
a multidimensional picture of
Jewish life before and during
World War Two.
Peretz H.
was born in 1927
in Warsaw.
He was a child when the war broke
out.
He used to sing in the streets
of Warsaw to earn a living,
and he shared several songs
in his 1993
Fortunoff video archive testimony.
One of them is Walc François,
Waltz François, composed
in 1905 by
Adam Józef Karasiński
to lyrics of Andrzej Włast.
That song was a salon waltz
that enjoyed enormous popularity
in Poland in the first half
of the 20th century.
There is no surprise that a song
written in what originally was
a sentimentalism era salon
genre, with the lyrics expressing
the longing for the Golden Times,
Golden Era of the past
gained such enormous popularity.
Walc François ended up
among many songs that
Peretz H.
was singing for his livelihood
during the war.
In my grandma's old music.
This waltz has survived.
I remember an evening at her place.
I see it as in a dream
A player at the piano.
Guests are gathering in a circle.
Ladies wear white puffs and bustles.
A chrysanthemum in each gentleman's
lapel.
The magic of yesteryear's memories.
The grace of elegant couples.
Muslin dresses flying like fog.
To the latest Waltz François.
If only, once again.
That beautiful time would return.
If only it would evoke in these
hearts of evil.
The magic of that French waltz.
In my grandma's old music.
This waltz has survived.
I remember an eveing at her place.
I see it as in a dream.
A player at the piano.
Guests are gathering in a circle.
Ladies wear white puffs and bustles.
A chrysanthemum in each gentleman's
lapel.
The magic of yesteryear's memories.
The grace of elegant couples.
Muslin dresses flying like fog.
To the latest Waltz François.
If only, once again.
That beautiful time would return.
If only it would evoke in these
hearts of evil.
The magic of that French Waltz.
A player at the piano.
Guests are gathering in a circle.
Ladies wear white puffs and bustles.
A chrysanthemum in each gentleman's
lapel.
The magic of yesteryear's memories.
the grace of elegant couples.
Muslin dresses flying like fog.
To the latest Waltz François.
If only, once again.
That beautiful time would return.
If only it would evoke in these
hearts of evil.
The magic of that French waltz.
The magic of yesteryear's memories.
the grace of elegant couples.
Muslin dresses flying like fog.
To the latest Waltz François.
If only, once again.
That beautiful time would return.
If only it would evoke in these
hearts of evil.
The magic of that French waltz.
Walc François
belongs to this repertoire of
street musicians, singers
who wanted to survive
during German occupation
in Warsaw.
Using
hits from pre-war
time
to make a living
to survive.
And in many cases, these
hits came
from abroad to Poland.
That was the case of
"Cielito Lindo."
But this is not the case of Walc
François. It
originated from this very
unique milieu
of pre-war
Polish Jewish artistic
circles
on the turn of 19,
20 centuries.
And there are some
special characters
of this story which I
would like to
say a few words about.
The first is
Adam Karasiński, a
Polish musician and composer
who is the author of Walc
François.
It was
the year of 1905.
A reception
devoted to his
mus-- colleague, the
composer and friend.
And on that
very party, he,
for the first time performs this
melody of Walc François,
which quickly gain
in popularity and
became one of the main
Polish waltz melodies.
And the Karasiński
was called the King of
Polish waltz, at that
time.
He died in 1920.
And he,
so there is, we have a family,
Polish Jewish family.
His wife was Jewish and
the son, Zbigniew Karasiński,
became a new editor,
now author of new version of
this song in 1920.
Zbigniew Karasiński is
a very, very interesting
personality.
He became one of the
pioneers of
Polish jazz.
And before the war,
during the war and after the war
time, he was very engaged in
developing
the orchestra's compositions.
Concerts devoted to
mostly jazz music.
Also popular music.
But when
the year 1968 came,
this anti-Semitic
action by the
communist regime in Poland, he
emigrated
abroad. So
this is one,
one part of that story from
the Karasiński's
family and
another character very important,
it may be the crucial one
for the popularity of our song.
It's Andrzej Włast,
a
Polish Jew coming
from Łódź who
came to Warsaw
at that time, and
it became one
of the major figures of developing
so-called Polish mass culture
with radios, cover ads and
so on.
Many people consider him the
first
person who who
was confident about
the need of mass
culture in a
new postwar post
First World War, Poland
at that time.
So firstly, he started to cooperate
with the most famous and I think
the best cover we had
in pre-war time in Poland quid pro
quo  was such
names
as Julian Tuwim
and Hemar.
Comparing to Andrzej Włast
as they were more ambitious,
the poetry, the lyrics
was on that higher level.
But Andrzej Włas
like to compose
and to produce
more, popular
repertoire, less ambitious.
That's why he was called
"Król Szmiry" in
pre war Warsaw, the king
of Szmira, which is a
less than ambitious repertoire
softly saying.
But
there were, of course, the purest of
poetry in his lyrics
as well.
He was an author of such songs
as "Rebeka",
very popular.
Also after the war, especially when
Ewa Demarczyk started to perform it,
and he he was the author
of the,
the lyrics to
Walc François.
And it became a hit
of a new cover that he established
in 1927 in Warsaw,
which was called
"Morskie Oko", "Sea eye".
Which was called
Warsaw's,
Casino de Paris,
because it was
influenced very heavily
by the French
tradition of
rewja and cabaret,
especially Casino de Paris also
Moulin Rouge and others.
He was traveling very often to Paris
at that time and
taking the models and the
the inspiration from that tradition.
And it was very much about
these culture in Warsaw,
it was a very much French oriented.
And
that was also the reason that Warsaw
was called at that time, the Paris
of the North.
And Andrzej Włast was
very responsible for
for that title.
And we, we may understand why
it was called Walc François,
the French culture was very
attractive and
at the background of
this
music.
Andrzej Włast
also composed,
he was the author of such
hits
as a lyrics
writer as "Tango Milonka,"
is the
most popular composition
at that time coming from Poland,
composed by Jerzy Petersburski.
And with international
fame among
the singers performing
this composition was Édith
Piaf.
And
it was also performed on Broadway
in
Al Jolson Music halls.
So very successful hit
coming also from that
milieu in Warsaw.
The, this,
worthwhile to mention also
very tragic fate of
Andrzej Włast during the
Holocaust. He, he was
closed in Warsaw Ghetto.
And there are different variants
of his death, one
of them is saying that
his friends make
the whole action to
take him out from the Warsaw
ghetto. But when
he saw German soldiers,
he went to panic and was
shot down at
the spot.
We don't know exactly how
how it was, but he
perished in that
time in Warsaw.
What about
the
later
history of our
song, it
is still popular
in Poland.
You may find it
in such productions
as the
TV series, "God
lining" "Boża Podszewka",
very popular in Poland in the 90s
of recent of last century.
But mainly the
living off of this
song and composition
is
because it's
popularity is because
the performance, by Tadeusz Kantor
of that
class, from
1975.
And there is an anecdote
behind it, why Kantor
used this melody
in his performance
was it his wife, Maria
Stangret,
who was humming
during the
presence in one of the Kraków
café, humming this melody
and kind of immediately said,
"Oh this is the melody for
our performance." Why
I think that it was
the whole performance,
which is one of the most
important performance of 20th
century, not only Polish theater.
The reason for that,
I think, is that the
whole performance is about coming
back to our childhood time,
to our school time,
to revolve the memories,
of some traumatic memories from
the very time.
And this melody serves
on that there in
that, in
this case, very
strongly.
So when we think today
about the Walc François,
it's very much about coming
back to our childhood,
to our past
with nostalgia, with kind
of feeling that
we we still
have of
returning to better
times, to the
golden age, something
like that. And precisely
that was
the reason Kantor used
forces, very dramatic performers.
And, and that is, there is no
other music in that performance,
only it's like like light motif,
from the beginning to the end.
Repeated and repeated in that
performance and
almost conducted by
Kantor who was
present on the stage
and,
and conducting
this music.
So we still keep it
in our minds, in our hearts,
in our culture.
And we should remember,
mostly, I sing the last
verses of the song, which
goes "Gdyby zbudził w sercach złych
ludzi, Czar modnego
Walca François",
"If only it would evoke in these
hearts of evil, the
magic of that
French waltz".
I think we should still
do our best
to keep it, to keep this magic,
to counter the evil in our hearts.